can I tell you speaking of your father
my father came and you were very
gracious and went to their hotel and
said hello I was very gracious you gave
me no warning at all I get a call from
my assistant Sona like at the last
second and she said Heath parents are in
town he wants you to meet them and I
said well it's like a Saturday and she
said he wants you to meet them there at
this hotel and you put them up at a very
nice hotel well thank you yeah did I pay
for that you son of a I had no idea I
couldn't believe I will I'm gonna say it
I don't care
visa I said alright where are they off
which Best Western are they
I literally did I that's where I put my
parents and I'm like which one and my
sister said Beverly Hills Hotel
that's like Beverly Hills Hotel and I go
through there by the pool like ordering
suits made I think sculpture it's
brought in and shown to them yeah put it
in the car I was shocked that this early
in the process you would let your
parents near your show I've never let my
parents near my show and actually for 20
years whenever we had a skit that
involved my mom we would hire an actress
and each time a different actress so my
mom has been played by hundreds of
different women who look nothing like
what and she's always at home like well
oh I would be remiss if I didn't say
thank you
are you winding this thing up yeah I'm
starting up no I'm starting it starting
why this is fun
what we don't have to go anywhere let's
say I got to do
oh no I'm not wrapping it up
I'm not wrapping it up I thought when
you said I thought you were trying to
get me uh no no no cuz I've nowhere to
go this is the sad part of my night I
live for the show and then the shows are
over and right I just I hang around the
office and people like you've got a wife
and kids you should get home and I'm
like I know I have dropped by after your
taping and I've heard you say - soda
Sona do I have anything and she goes
just to children and you go we're going
to dinner I have an agent a manager that
take good care now III I do I do get
home in time to see the kids that's nice
yeah what's this is the part we pretend
I'm a nice guy